[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le sais tu ce
week-end sur tv 78 actualité idées de
sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines voici le programme de
ce 22 avril
une firme qui produit plus de 30
variétés de fruits légumes et aromates
jusque là rien d'étonnant sauf qu'elle
est installée dans un souterrain et la
culture se fait hors sol une start-up
francilienne a lancé le concept depuis
un an à sartrouville
c'est un rendez vous culturel phare de
l'été à versailles le mois molière se
déroule en juin la 26e édition a été
présentée ce jeudi une programmation
spécialement dédiée au dramaturge dont
nous célébrons cette année le 400e
anniversaire françois de mazières maire
de versailles est notre invité et puis
comme tous les vendredis nos idées de
sorties pour le week-end avec un focus
spécial sur les vacances de printemps
qui démarre ce soir pour les yvelinois
il ya un yves launoy qui est
particulièrement heureux d'être en
vacances ce soir enfin il n'est pas
vraiment en vacances mais il est avec
moi en plateau c'est bixente dernières
sorties steban heureux que les vacances
débutent puisque il y aura votre
sélection d'idées de sorties et
forcément beaucoup d'idées de sorties en
ces vacances de printemps et il y aussi
un invité exceptionnel dans ce set week
end oui exactement grégory j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer un clémence castel
alors double gagnante de koh lanta en
2005 et 2018 elle est venue à france
miniature nous présenter un peu le
nouvel espace dédié à la célèbre
émission donc des jeux d'eau des
épreuves voilà plein de choses pour se
régaler en famille on a vu un petit
aperçu vous avez fait votre choix tribu
jaune tribunes rouge moi j'avais le la
tribu jaune mois et on a vu qu elle l
avait son foulard de jay z de tribus
rouge et on en parlera tout à l'heure
bien sûr on vous retrouve tout à l'heure
dans le sais tu ce week-end
ce n'était qu'un parking désaffecté il y
a un an c'est maintenant une ferme
urbaine de 1300 m² produisent en fruits
légumes et aromates on culture hors sol
créé par la start-up chant perché en
2010 est cette firme basée à
sartrouville exploite le concept de la
bio peau ni explication dans ce
reportage de céline charles
[Musique]
bienvenue séchant perché ici on se
trouve au niveau du coeur un petit peu
du système puisque ces deux là où
partiront toutes nos solutions grâce à
un ensemble de ces cons à la fois
d'allers et de retours on a constamment
de l'eau et donc de la solution
organique qu'on appelle chez nous aux
assauts qui est diffusé dans toutes nos
plantes chant perché sait déjà c'est une
entreprise qui a pour but de nourrir
tout le monde sans carences de manière
écologique il faut savoir qu'en moyenne
la distance entre le chant et la société
de 700 kilomètres sont perchés a pour
but de réduire cette distance à 7 km
donc vous avez un peu le résumé de la
bio pony dans toutes ses salles donc le
principe est simple ou cultura base de
substrats organiques complémenter de
l'aide agricole et avec ça en rajoutent
des insectes on implante nous-mêmes pour
lutter contre les ravageurs il faut
savoir que chez nous le soleil c'est des
lampes à gries cole qui sont optimisés
exprès pour la culture de plantes avec
des cycles jour nuit comme ce que vous
trouvez dans la nature donc vous avez
ici par exemple de la mélisse là vous
avez du basilic grand verre et en fait
grâce à des systèmes de coupe optimisé
dit en bonsaï dans le déni du bonsaï on
obtient des rendements assez important
il faut savoir que par mètre carré on
est deux cent seize fois plus productif
qu'un agriculteur classique en
consommant 90 fonctions de haut - sans
consommer de gm ni aucun produit
phytosanitaire
on a trois types de clients on a les
restaurateurs les
grandes et moyennes surfaces et aussi
quelques réseaux dame à petit la ruche
qui dit oui mais il faut savoir que la
particularité de chercher c'est que nos
clients se situe dans un rayon de 20 km
on a aussi un atelier de transformation
qui nous permet en fait de gérer tout le
surplus donc quand on a une
surproduction par exemple de base libre
en mer eh bien on va le transformer en
pesto nous avons comme projet d'ouvrir
plusieurs fermes dans les hybrides d'ici
à 2026 environ afin de pouvoir
autonomiser ce territoire notamment sur
des espèces on pourrait sur certaines
espèces exotiques est de rendre les
mines 100% autonome en construction
[Musique]
la semaine qui se clôture dans les
yvelines a été plutôt courte avec en
début de semaine le lundi de pâques
férié mais l'actualité ne s'est pas
arrêtée ce qu'il faut retenir en 78
secondes c'est avec céline charles
[Musique]
une belle initiative pour nos amis les
chats à chanteloup-les-vignes une petite
cabane est maintenant mise à disposition
des chats du quartier à l'intérieur de
la chaleur et de la nourriture en libre
service côté sport le footballeur
yvelinois aurélien collin a décidé de
prendre sa retraite à 36 ans il avait
notamment remporté le championnat
américain de la major league soccer une
partie de la route nationale 12 a été
fermée dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi
en cause un exercice de sécurité civile
dans le tunnel de chennevières au niveau
de jouars-pontchartrain un feu de forêt
s'est déclaré dans la commune de
rochefort en yvelines 70 pompiers et une
trentaine de camions ont été mobilisés
sur place plus de 8 hectares ont été
brûlés mais aucune habitation n'a été
impactée un contrat historique pour
ariane space filiale d'ariane groupe
basé aux mureaux dans le cadre du projet
keeper d'amazon 18 lancements de la
fusée ariane 6 vont être effectués et
puis côté loisirs un nouvel espace koh
lanta a été inaugurée pour la
réouverture annuelle du parc france
miniature avec la présence de clémence
castel double gagnante de l'émission
petits et grands pourront s'affronter
durant une série d'épreuves
[Musique]
et donc l'interview de clémence castel à
suivre dans cette émission avec bixente
de retour tout à l'heure dans cette
émission est dernières semaines
également avant le deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle c'est ce
dimanche les français sont appelés à
élire leur président de la république
mais comment fonctionne un bureau de
vote raphaël mata juninho du collectif
des surligneurs répond à cette question
c'est au menu ce soir de notre rubrique
légal chez king
comment fonctionne un bureau de vote sur
le code électoral un bureau de vote est
composé d'un président de deux
assesseurs et d'un secrétaire de membres
au moins doivent rester présents tout au
long du scrutin le président du bureau
ou à défaut la cession de plus âgée et
un assesseur l'assesseur est un électeur
chargé d'accompagner le président du
bureau de vote afin de s'assurer que le
scrutin se déroule dans le respect de la
loi ils vérifient l'identité des
électeurs leur inscription sur liste
électorale surveille la signature
vérifie la valider des procurations et
participe à l'organisation du
dépouillement chaque candidat ou liste a
le droit de désigner par bureau de vote
un assesseur parmi les électeurs le
maire peut également désigner les
assesseurs parmi les conseils municipaux
et parmi les électeurs de la commune
par ailleurs les partis politiques sont
invités à désigner des délégués en tant
qu'observateur et et moi ils ne font pas
partie du bureau de vote mais veillent à
ce que les opérations de vote s'effectue
dans le respect du code électoral il
contrôle les opérations de dépouillement
et de décompte des voix ils peuvent
également contesté la validité de
certains bulletins et inscrire leurs
observations sur le procès verbal du
bureau en vue d'un éventuel contentieux
assesseurs et des délégués mène donc
ensemble un double combat d'abord
s'assurer de la régularité du scrutin
qui englobe les aspects procéduraux
telles que la présence document
distractif des isoloirs des bulletins de
vote et c'est ensuite respecter la
sincérité du scrutin qui implique non
seulement l'égalité des conditions delà
de la compétition entre les candidats
mais aussi du décompte des voix et de la
liberté de choix un électeur égale une
voix et chaque électeur doit garder son
vote secret et doit effectuer son choix
en toute conscience et en suivant sa
seule volonté sans pression extérieure y
compris au sein du bureau de vote c'est
la garantie de la démocratie
et nous reviendrons lundi sur les
résultats de ce deuxième tour l'élection
présidentielle avec une émission
spéciale édition spéciale la rédaction
de tv 78 à partir de 18h à un rendez
vous culturel phare à présent c'est le
mois molière qui revient en juin à
versailles la 26e édition se dévoile
puisqu'elle a été a présenté hier jeudi
à paris pour en parler mon invité en
visioconférence françois de mazières
bonjour
mr de versailles et surtout créateur de
ce mois molière sai on est dans la
dernière ligne droite j'imagine c'est un
rendez vous que vous attendez avec
impatience chaque année dans la sphère
royal oui bien sûr parce que donc là ça
sera la 26e édition
c'est un mois qui s'est inscrit un
festival dans la durée maintenant est
très connu et versailles et mais bien au
delà c'est un festival aussi un peu
particulier puisque ont fait aussi le
400e anniversaire de la naissance de
molière quand tu as
maintenant
1996 et la première édition de ce
festival est pourquoi je les prie
seconde mois molière c'est parce qu'il
ya un lien évident on trouve je crois
qu'on a tous je vends française celui
qui a inventé un peu la comédie à la
française et ville de versailles molière
on le sait est venu plusieurs fois à
versailles est venu jouer ses pièces
créées certaines de ces pièces dont 763
ya l'impromptu de versailles je voudrais
qu'on en parle juste après puisque ce
sera l'ouverture de ce mois molière on
va venir sur la programmation juste sur
l'objectif il ya une vraie volonté aussi
de
mettre en avant des talents c'est une
pépinière de talents ce mois molière on
précise tout de même ce chiffre 11
compagnies qui sont accueillis en
résidence à versailles alan est
tout à fait dans la spécificité du moins
boullier il doit d'abord ça toujours été
un festival que je dirais populaire de
qualité l'année dans la grande tradition
des bals qui est bien sûr la référence
absolue étant impossible des réunions
mais en cette année celle qui pomme
envie de théâtre s'est investie à qui va
même région et dans la spécificité et la
programmation ce que j'ai c'est que
maintenant depuis sa création c'est de
pousser des jeunes compagnie des jeunes
compagnies qui parfois sont venus très
connus comme michel inc alexis michalik
aujourd'hui nous avons et répondront
aussi qui est un record nominés cette
année pour son spectacle le titre mais
un spectacle était à privé est nominé on
verra si il a à nouveau
le trophée combien valait cas payet
quelques années mais nous avons aussi
une autre actrice monde et y danse ici
qui est éliminé c'est le bilan en tant
qu'actrice mais en fait si vous voulez
une des ses ventes et un peu une
pépinière de talents comme ça a été du
top 14 c'est une tradition qu'on essaie
de matraquer 4 sur sur cette édition il
y aura 3 130 représentations 60 lieux
mille comédiens musiciens vous l'avez
dit cette année année particulière
puisque c'est l'année du 400e
anniversaire de la naissance de molière
dont puis une programmation vraiment
particulière dédiée à molières cette
année en plus d'un événement qui qui
porte son nom et on vous en parlait tout
à l'heure françois de mazières à
l'ouverture de ce mois molière qui aura
lieu le 1er juin avec une pièce
l'impromptu de versailles une histoire
particulière puisqu'elle a été créée en
16 163 à versailles justement par par
molière c'est pas forcément la plus
connue mais elle a une histoire
particulière et un lien particulier avec
avec la ville de versailles
c'est une pièce qui est rarement joué
parce que d'abord c'est une pièce en
moins c'est une pièce qui est plus
courte que les autres que les plus
célèbres du répertoire de mouiller elle
est dure à peu près 50 nuitées donc dans
les mises en scène on s'arrange pour que
le cac est généralement une heure un peu
plus raconté s'il pièce particulièrement
intéressante célébrer mourir parce que
c'est celle où il se met lui même en
scène le personnage principal de la
pièce ses volumes il s'appelle bolliet
et les autres personnages ce sont les
acteurs de la troupe de molière pourquoi
ans qu'elle est la thématique de la
poule c'est le fait que nos liens a été
opposée au mouvement né en
563 il créé cette pièce et comme l'a dit
que non c'est d'un apprenti c'est une
pièce très très rapidement mais c'est
une réponse à la critique à la kabbale
qui avaient eu lieu contre molière au
moment où il avait présenté l'écho des
femmes donc c'est une question
extrêmement intéressante parce qu'elle
parle de monnaie à lui même et tous deux
sont des lecteurs et il répond aux
critiques qui me fait notamment repart
accompagné contre qui et c'est pourquoi
la troupe de blogueurs dont
un des acteurs
célèbres à des portes est très critique
aussi mobilières et de moyens ce mot si
c'est entre guillemets concours et donc
elle sera jouée pour l'ouverture de ce
molière par la compagnie vival on arrive
peu à peu à la fin de cet entretien on
pourrait en parler pendant pendant des
heures mais que faut-il retenir de la
programmation il ya 330 représentation
va pas tout les présenter mais ce qui
est un fil conducteur on l'a dit c'est
vraiment dédié à molières en se cette
26e édition alors il me faut du temps
c'est bon c'est une partie qui est sur
molière et le ciel de la guerre pas
uniquement sous les pièces riez vous
avez d'ailleurs des créations d'auteurs
contemporains
s'il ya une pièce de jean philippe
daguerre qui a ainsi connu aussi qu'a
fait monsieur madame quitte à un auteur
quand on prend un théâtre français ce
qui est vraiment très reconnue et lui a
dédié ce dont j'ai envie d'écrire une
pièce sur molière elle voyage est voilà
typiquement oui c'est pas de nous
répéter en direct de regard mais c'est
au tour de molière et de socié mais à
côté de ça vous avez aussi des pièces
qui ont été des succès de l'année
dernière elle crée souvent avignon dans
cette crise et que qui sont là et qui
est ont été invités parce qu'on sait que
le public soit content de les découvrir
en salles pour résumer ce mécanisme très
diversifié avec des chaînes de création
n'est aussi des reprises et on sait que
la marque de caves et de ces festivals
cédait dans tous les quartiers il ya
soixante mille représentations il ya un
autre lourde honneur comment avignon
celle lui principal un peu mythique est
bien pour nous c'est les grandes écuries
du château de versailles c'est là où il
y en aura mais si on me dira que
officiel où tout aussi beaucoup deux
spectacles de musique bref un grand
quine estivale et je précise juste que y
aura aussi un rendez vous phare au delà
des représentations c'est les rencontres
internationales 1 qui auront lieu les 9
et 10 juin au théâtre montansier on
retrouve bien sûr toute la programmation
du mois molière sur le site internet
dédié qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci françois de mazières d'avoir été
avec nous
à bientôt à bientôt au maire de
versailles et créateur de ce mois
molière qui arrive donc en juin dans la
cité royale mais avant ce week-end il y
à d'autres idées de sorties à faire dans
les yvelines on voit ça tout de suite
dans le sahtu ce week-end
et c'est avec bien sûr bixente mais rien
senti steban qui est de retour en
plateau pour ses idées de sorties on l'a
dit en début d'émission c'est ce soir ce
vendredi soir le début des vacances de
printemps mais en effet pour l'occasion
j'ai missionné notre journaliste bien
aimé michael et me d'euros pour
rechercher fouillé inspecté tout le
département et vous proposer un top 5
des activités à faire pendant ces
vacances de printemps
[Musique]
vous est prévu quoi ce week end bixente
à leur tour des grandes eaux à
versailles ça toujours à un moment sympa
de l'année après les lanières de thoiry
c'est un petit budget donc faut voir
avec c'est un grand classique ces
grandes eaux musicales au château de
versailles alors je sais que c'est l'une
de vos émissions préférées après le 7-8
week-end bien sûr bixente beaucoup de
téléspectateurs j'en suis sûr la suivent
régulièrement c'est koh lanta et vous
avez rencontrés ils encourent l'une des
légendes de ce jeu télévisé c'est ça
comme on le disait en début d'émission
il s'agit d'une double gagnante clémence
castel rien que ça la star de koh lanta
était à france miniature cette semaine
afin d'inaugurer le tout nouvel espace
dédié à la célèbre émission j'ai pu
découvrir les lieux avec elle regardez
ne pas france miniature a rouvert ses
portes le 9 avril dernier avec cette
année une nouveauté un espace entier
dédié à l'univers koh lanta et pour en
parler qui de mieux qu'une double
gagnante en 2005 et 2018 clémence castel
bonjour bonjour est ce que vous avez eu
le temps déjà de faire un petit tour sur
le lieu commence commencé ici
effectivement j un petit tour sur le
lieu avec mes enfants en plus donc
qu'ils sont les meilleurs testeurs je
pense pour pour cet univers et voilà
dans cet univers on retrouve l'univers
koh lanta évidemment et toutes les
épreuves qui vont avec il ya une épreuve
de chasse au trésor c'est un milieu très
très aquatique donc forcément dans koh
lanta on retrouve de l'eau que ce soit
sur les plages ou même
par la pluie malheureusement parfois
comme celui des retraites très aquatique
et puis voilà il ya toute une structure
en bois en bouquet rail qui rappelle les
preuves d des bambous dans koh lanta et
voilà pour tous les fans de l'émission
ben voilà ils vont retrouver tout tout
ce qui entoure et tout ce qui fait rêver
dans koh lanta c'est à dire laventure le
dépassement de soi et je suis sûr que
les familles vont passer un très bon
moment dans cet univers que vous aviez
vous avez pu vous essayer à quelque
chose est-ce qu'il ya votre une épreuve
de prédilection un jeu que vous préférez
plus que les autres a pas forcément les
poteaux c'est une épreuve que
j'affectionne particulièrement et ils
sont présents dans dans cet univers là
c'est super parce qu'ils restent
accessibles à une hauteur accessibles
des plus jeunes donc on peut y
participer en famille et c'est ça que je
trouve génial de toucher du doigt
l'ambiance de koh lanta à 25 km de paris
et qu'ils pouvaient en famille donc
c'est vraiment super c'est un univers
qui essaye de se représenter aussi
l'univers comme ça quand vous avez dit
aussi le parc france miniature qui est
un peu un espace ludique où on apprend
ça c'est ça représente bien ces valeurs
là ici cet îlot de commentaires mais en
fait moi ça c'est ma première france
miniature aujourd'hui j'ai eu l'occasion
de déjà faire un tour et ce qui est
génial c'est que effectivement on voit
tous les monuments français et ça m'a
déjà permis de d'expliquer beaucoup de
choses à mes enfants donc ça c'est
génial et puis et tu vois là il ya le
côté ludique aussi
jeu à l'univers kolontar on touche du
doigt le l'esprit un petit peu des îles
etc tout en s'amusant donc donc tout est
réuni pour passer un bon moment donc ça
vient aussi à la suite d'un autre
univers fort boyard que vous avez fait
aussi une fois ouais ce que vous avez le
temps de visiter un peu la salle l'antre
du père fouras oui je suis allé dans
l'univers fort boyard c'est une émission
qui envoya requis a commencé quand
j'avais 5 ans et je me rappelle très
bien de la première année c'est une
émission qui a plus de 30 ans
aujourd'hui et qui m'a fait rêver en
tant que jeune fille petite fille donc
voilà on en a déjà fait des épreuves
avec des enfants où on peut se mesurer
les uns aux autres dans un bon état
d'esprit et voilà que soit 1000 r
koh-lanta l'univers fort boyard c'est
tout ce que j'aime le côté aventure le
côté dépassements et et voilà je suis
chaque apprendre apprentis aventuriers à
venir ici découvrir tous ces univers bon
j'aurais bien aimé vous affrontez haut à
l'épreuve des poteaux de l'espoir de
toute façon j'aurais perdu c'est
peut-être un peu tôt
mais voilà si vous voulez n'y a pas ici
j'ai trois heures devant moi donc ce
n'est pas de problème
pour le défier lancer l'épreuve des
poteaux ses autres défis préférait dans
koh lanta des bosses un peu c'est un peu
long peut-être pour moi je pense que
j'ai peut-être pas la patience mais il
ya quelques épreuves et j'affectionne
particulièrement en effet et on remercie
clémence castel pour sa disponibilité
alors que lanta dans les yvelines c'est
un peu insolite on peut le dire bixente
et justement il ya des idées de sorties
originales aussi à faire dans le
département puisque le département
regorge de lieux insolites oui on se
rend à chambourcy il se dit même que
certains camps mauricien c'est comme ça
qu'on les appelle n'ont jamais visité ce
lieu et bien c'est l'occasion puisque le
30 avril prochain le désert de red ouvre
ses portes pour une visite guidée un
jardin anglo chinois du xviiie siècle
nous avons demandé plusieurs fois la
directrice de l'office du tourisme de
saint germain boucles de seine céline
interview express
c'est une visite guidée qui dure à peu
près une heure trente et on vous emmène
en fait au désert de red hat chambourcy
qui est inquiète un parc roulant chinois
vous allez découvrir l'histoire et puis
ce lieu un peu empreint de magie c'est à
14 euros par adulte et 8 euros par
enfant et en fait on organise des
visites régulières dont celle du 30
avril
[Musique]
c'est un lieu assez original en fait
déjà le nom le désert de red ce donc le
désert en fait au xviiie siècle c'était
un endroit retiré dans un enclos qui le
tenait à l'écart du monde reste en fait
c'est le tout simplement c'est le lieu
en fait où françois de montville achète
à saint-jacques de raids c'est un
terrain une parcelle de 30 hectares où
il installe en fait donc ce parc avec
des fabriques
[Musique]
certains vous êtes passionné par
l'histoire de ce lieu les personnalités
qui ont été accueillis daudou est
passionné par les essences rares que
vous pouvez y trouver les plus petits
vont adorer un peu se balader même si
souvent sous la responsabilité des
parents donc c'est un lieu qui parle un
peu un tout bon
[Musique]
là une dernière idée à bixente à vélo
ont ce week-end c'est râpé a priori la
météo sera pas au rendez-vous mais
normalement la semaine prochaine
peut-être dimanche un peu de soleil
prévu pour pourquoi pas sillonné le
département oui c'est toujours
sympathique d'arpenter les villes les
campagnes en pédalant et encore plus
lorsque c'est pour défendre les couleurs
du département l'application de
randonnée avait logé au vélo lance
l'événement du mais à vélo pendant un
mois il s'agira de parcourir un maximum
de kilomètres dans les yvelines pour
donner à son département le meilleur
classement possible en france est-ce que
les yvelines peuvent réveiller en tête
qui brille quoi qu'on en dise in terre
de vélo et les yvelines voilà donc c'est
le moment de le prouver en tout cas pour
s'inscrire et participer rendez vous sur
le site où l'application de géo vélo
merci bixente pour ses idées de sorties
et une fois n'est pas coutume nous
allons refermer cette émission sur une
session de recrutement le 27 le 27 avril
prochain elle les agences babychou
services de versailles
saint-germain-en-laye et
maisons-laffitte organise un job dating
à destination de leurs futurs alternant
80 postes sont à pourvoir pour les
candidats qui souhaitent se former à la
garde d'enfants à domicile pour
comprendre quel est le contenu de cette
formation c'est ap accompagnement
éducatif petite enfance nous avons suivi
collins et diaga tsongo bixente mais
rien senti steban et mélanie poquet pour
le sujet depuis tout petit moins c'est
les enfants donc page poursuit cette
branche loire depuis la rentrée scolaire
colline schlaeppi 22 ans est en
formation ans et ap accompagnement
éducatif petite enfance au sein de
l'association des cours professionnels
de pharmacie santé sanitaire et social à
poissy on apprend tout le sommeil on
apprend la nutrition on apprend
comment réagir face à un enfant qui est
qui mécontents qui fait une crise on
apprend vraiment tout autour de l'enfant
en fait en alternance dans l'entreprise
bay beach ou services coline coupe sa
journée en deux le matin elles assistent
aux cours et l'après midi elle garde des
enfants le ca permet de réviser la
partie théorique tout le côté nutrition
de l'enfant tout côté sécurité de
l'enfant également tout le côté éveil le
côté psychomoteur également c'est une
formation il s'appelait s'adresse
vraiment
à la garde d'enfants de 0 à 6 ans
l'après-midi colline va chercher à
l'école aloïs et gustave cela fait sept
mois qu'elle s'occupe de ses enfants du
lundi au vendredi de 16 heures à 19
heures 15 tout dépend en fait des gens
des ya des jours où il ya des activités
sportives donc du coup je suis plus avec
halloween je vais le chercher en premier
on rentre directement semble petit on
fait aller voir les goûters et après je
l'emmène et ensuite je vais chercher les
petits quand il a du temps dans un bon
jour on lit on met de la musique on s'en
fout on a rencontré colline en septembre
et ça s'est fait très naturellement que
le dîner
super réactive très apprécié des enfants
un vrai plaisir au quotidien brède b
biche ou services spécialisée dans la
garde d'enfants à domicile met en
relation leurs alternant et des familles
qui ont des besoins spécifiques pour les
apprenants le terrain leur fournit des
compétences gagne en autonomie en
maturité professionnelle sens de
l'organisation
répondre aux objectifs qui sont fixées
par par l' agence mais sans fixer soi
même aussi au jour le jour les agences
babychou services de versailles
saint-germain-en-laye et
maisons-laffitte organise un job dating
dédié à l'alternance le 27 avril
prochain le but recruté 80 postes
d'alternants pour septembre 2022 donc
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
cette émission merci bixente de m'avoir
accompagné nouvelle fois dans cette
décision puisque réussi avec plaisir et
bon week end à vous c'est toujours un
plaisir autour de l'information sur tv
60,18 lundi avec une édition spéciale
qui sera consacrée aux résultats du
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle et d'ici là passez un
excellent week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]